But what about the reliability and
the MTTF of Raid 1?
Same as before, we'll assume that
some F is the failure rate for
a single disk in failures
per disk per second.
And for a single disk remember that
the MTTF is simply one over F,
where F is that failure rate.
And then the mean time to data loss,
which is the MTTF,
really, of the whole disk array,
in this case just one disk, would be
simply the MTTF of that one disk.
Well, let's say now that we
have two disks in RAID 1.
And remember that the failure rate
when we have more than one disk
is N times the failure rate of one disk
as long as all of the disks are working.
So what we have really is that
both of our disks in raid one
are okay until the time,
entity of one disk over two.
This is the expected time when
one of the disks will fail.
Now, unlike raid zero,
where this is the point where we would
lose data, now we have mirroring.
So both of the disks need to fail in
order for the whole thing to lose data.
One failure is not data loss yet,
so we don't have the failure
of the array yet, but this time,
we are down to one disk.
That one disk is a working disk,
and has this failure rate.
So, that one remaining disk will live
on for another MTTF of a single disk.
This is very important to understand.
If we have a working disk at
some point in time, the MTTF for
that disc is going to be,
the overall MTTF for one disc.
This MTTF is not affected
by the fact that this disk
has already been working for
all this time.
Why?
Well because the failure rate is
constant, it's not affected by time.
So if we have a working disk,
its failure rate is always the same.
The only thing that changes
the failure rate is if the disk fails.
So if we had two disks and both work,
this is the expected time of them
surviving, and then if we're down to
one disk that works, at the time when
we have a single working disk this
is the MTTF that we can expect.
So overall, the mean time to data loss
for RAID1 with two disks is going to be
the MTTF of a single disk over two,
plus the MTTF of a single disk.
And now, we bought two disks, and
used them in an array that has
the capacity of only a single disk.
So we basically paid for the extra disk,
just to get reliability.
And what we get is just one
half more of the MTTF then
we would normally get
with only a single disk.
So what's the point?
The point is that this calculation
assumes that no disk is replaced
at the time when it fails.
So we had the failure and
we just let that fail disk just be
there and we were down to one disk and
didn't fix it and then we were just down
to the entity F of one disk for awhile.
But remember that when we want
reliability we definitely will
replace the failed disks.
So when we have the first failure we
will as soon as possible replace that
failed disk.
Copy the data from
the working disk to it so
now we're back to RAID1
working properly.
So what's the MTTF for that?